in 2009 District 9 became the surprise
hit movie of the year on a budget of
just $30 million the movie went on to
make $210 million at the worldwide box
office and was nominated for four
Academy Awards including best Motion
Picture although it didn't win any
Oscars District 99's breakout success
was an impressive feed for an indie
sci-fi film out of South Africa with a
firsttime writer director that featured
no movie stars so why wasn't a sequel to
District 9 ever made here's why a
standalone story according to District 9
Mastermind Neil Blum Camp he wasn't even
thinking about making a sequel while
writing directing and editing the film
since Blum Camp was only planning on
making a standalone film he didn't set
up the overall story Ark for a sequel or
a franchise it was only after the film
was edited that Blom Camp realized there
was room for a sequel but he still had
no idea where that sequel would go he
also toyed around with making a prequel
instead Blom Camp told hero complex in
2010 I'm not so interested in aliens
coming back and blowing things up but a
prequel might be interesting obviously
that idea never left the ground either
and it wasn't until 2015 that Blum Camp
said that he had a really cool idea for
a District 9 sequel does that mean that
a sequel is finally on the way at the
moment it doesn't look likely original
films in a perfect world production on a
District 9 sequel would have started
shortly after the first one was released
however without an idea for the sequel
Blum Camp instead used the success of
District 9 to get another original
sci-fi film into production within
months of District 99's release that
movie was aium which he worked on until
late 2012 while shooting aium Blom camp
and his wife/ co-screenwriter Terry
tachel wrote the script for chappie in 2
weeks and after aium wrapped they
immediately started working on that
production on that Movie lasted into
2014 and it was released in theaters in
February 2015 so yeah those movies kept
Blum Camp pretty busy post to District 9
Blum Camp told Rolling Stone that if he
were to do the sequel properly it would
take 3 years to make that's a big time
commitment or while the movie that set
it all off recedes into fans memories
other projects chappie was released in
May 2015 and although there hasn't been
much news about the director since then
Blum Camp has definitely been busy in
April 2017 Blum Camp revealed on Twitter
that he would be making experimental
short films for the video game platform
steam that's a big change from big
budget sci-fi flicks although at this
point in his career it's certainly less
risky than taking a chance on a sequel
to District 9 Blum Camp was also briefly
attached to director fifth entry in the
Alien series going so far as to release
tantalizing an official concept art on
Instagram but unfortunately that project
probably isn't happening in 2017 Blom
Camp tweeted The Awful Truth the chances
of his alien movie ever moving forward
are slim echoing an earlier tweet that
that the movie was set aside pending the
success of failure of alien Covenant
that doesn't mean that Blum Camp's
blogbuster days are over after all this
wouldn't be the first time Blum Camp has
bounced back after being sidelined on a
high-profile film Project originally
Blum Camp was picked by Peter Jackson to
direct a movie based on the Halo video
game franchise when Halo fell through
Jackson agreed to produce District 9
based on Blum Camp's 2006 short film
alive in joerg in other words the fact
that Blom Camp hasn't made a movie for
several years now doesn't mean that a
District 9 sequel will never happen
although it seems to be getting less and
less likely shalto Copley is busy too
although he looks different at the end
of the film shelto Copley is the face of
District 9 in his breakout role as a
delightfully clueless bureaucrats the
South African actor wowed International
audiences and launched his Hollywood
career but I don't trust it you know I
don't trust
anything are you
right because you right after chappie
copley's thirdd collaboration with Neil
Blom Camp the actor went on to star in
the PlayStation series powers and the
action thriller free fire as busy as he
is though Copley has made it clear that
he'd gladly reprise his role if a
District 9 sequel ever
materialized hard to follow up District
9 ended on a cliffhanger and the
universe of the film is Rich with themes
and story lines to explore Copley wants
to do a sequel and the movie was a huge
success for Peter Jackson's production
company in Hollywood that combination
usually adds up to a guaranteed Sequel
and yet the furthest in development that
District nine sequel ever got was an
18-page treatment one reason for that
may be because District nine was too big
of a hit its commentary on social
segregation xenophobia and racism
Blended perfectly with its sci-fi
aesthetic all of which helped it make it
an overwhelming success for the
firsttime writer director that's a hard
act to follow even when the ACT you're
following is your
own ah Hollywood it's a town where the
streets are paved with gold and dreams
die every single day seriously where's
that goon sequel we were promised and
what the heck happened to Inception 2
but while plenty of sequels to Mega hit
films have struggled and failed to claw
their way out of development hell few
follow-ups have endured more setbacks
than Gladiator 2 the longer waited
followup to one of Ridley Scott's most
popular movies Gladiator 2 has valiantly
tried to battle its way into theaters
but every time it rises up the film is
beaten back down it's time to grab your
sword and helmet and finally figure out
what happened well Maximus is dead when
Gladiator hit theaters in 2000 The Sword
and sandal epic wild critics it
currently holds an impressive score on
Rotten Tomatoes and it took home $457
million at the worldwide box office the
movie also fared well during Awards
season taking home the Oscar for best
picture and nabbing the best actor prize
for Russell Crow the film pretty much
turned Crow into an international
Superstar and nearly two decades later
people still shout lines like this are
you not entertained naturally with such
a massive hit on their hands DreamWorks
was quick to start developing a sequel
there was just one major Coliseum sized
problem with the idea Maximus Decimus
Meridius the main character of the movie
is kind of you know dead in the film's
climactic moments the evil Emperor
Commodus played by wackin Phoenix
challenges Maximus to a gladiator battle
there's no Universe where wacking
Phoenix beats Russell crow in
hand-to-hand combat but so Commodus
evens the odds by secretly stabbing
Maximus before tossing him into the
arena luckily Maximus is fueled by
revenge and rightous anger fighting
through the pain Maximus kills Commodus
with the emperor's own weapon before
drifting away into the wheat field
afterlife it was a killer ending for a
standalone film but it certainly makes
things tricky for a sequel but hey
Hollywood had gotten around this kind of
problem before right prequel problems
these days prequels are all the rage
with everything from Star Wars to X-Men
and the alien franchise going back to
move forward DreamWorks was looking to
do the same thing to get Maximus back
into the world of the living when people
started whispering about a new Gladiator
movie in 2001 the word on the web was
that the story would take place years
before the events of the first film it
was said to focus on maximus's early
days in the Roman military showing the
spaniard's rise from Mia Soldier to
Mighty General producer Douglas Wick
declared talks were underway to get the
ball rolling saying you don't finally do
something like glad to unless you have a
dazzling story to tell the studio was
reportedly looking to pay Crow as much
as $20 million to head back into the
arena the studio lined up David franzon
one of the original movies writers to
put the scripts together but much like a
Roman mob Hollywood can be
fickle and the project never made it out
of development shifting to a sequel
sometime between 2001 and 2002
DreamWorks decided to put the brakes on
a gladiator pre equal and shift their
focus to a sequel the first big change
involved David franzoni stepping away
from his typewriter to produce the
writing gig then went to John Logan
another one of the original Gladiator
writers with a new guy putting words on
the page the story was suddenly set 15
years after the events of the original
film that same year producer Walter
Parks hinted the film might possibly
jump back and forth in time but it would
mainly tell the story of Lucius the
royal son of Lucilla it would have
followed Lucius as the last heir of
Marcus orelus as he sought out his true
father who we would have discovered
would turn out to be Maximus director
Ridley Scott seemed on board with the
idea even declaring that Logan's script
was ready to go at one point however the
sequel was going to be significantly
different from the first film when it
came to action as Scott explained he
wasn't going to touch Gladiators again a
potentially controversial choice for a
movie tentatively called Gladiator 2
instead Scott was more interested in the
political Arena and wanted to focus on
politics and priorians rather than blood
and guts Scott also expected to start
filming in 2005 but as 2004 faded into
memory Gladiator 2 was still stuck in
the Cinematic mud but work continued and
the film eventually morphed into one of
the greatest movies never made Nick
caves Christ killer if you've ever heard
a Nick Cave song then you know the
Australian artist is basically an
old-timey Prophet armed with a guitar
his songs are brutal apocalyptic and
spiritual in an old Testament sort of
way and you get that same Vibe watching
the movies he's been involved with over
the years cave has composed music for
films like hell high water and the
assassination of Jesse James by the
coward Robert Ford he's also written
scripts for movies like Lawless and the
proposition with that kind of cinematic
mind it's not surprising that Russell
Crow saw potential in Cave's fire and
brimstone brain asking cave to write the
screenplay for Gladiator 2 what is a bit
surprising is how absolutely insane the
script turned out to be C didn't
disappoint when it came to figuring out
how to follow up maximus's death the
project was titled Christ killer and
would have opened in the afterlife with
Maximus realizing he's dead
unfortunately there's near a weat field
in sight and his wife and child are
nowhere to be seen eventually the
Gladiator comes face to face with the
dying Gods the decrepit deities make a
deal with Maximus promising to guide him
to his family if he'll kill a god who's
gone Rogue one who's betrayed the Roman
faith and now professes belief in the
one true God as Maximus agrees to do
their dirty work he eventually winds up
on Earth several years in the future
after returning to the real world he
discovers little Lucius has grown up to
be a Savage Soldier one with a bad habit
of violently murdering Christians
Maximus eventually takes a stand with
the persecuted Christians leading an
Army against the Roman Legions but after
his victory he's cursed to go through
time as an immortal fighting in
countless Wars and popping up in every
conflict from the Crusades to Vietnam if
you think that sounds wild we didn't
even mention the burg atory scene the
Coliseum filled with alligators or the
finale that takes place inside the
Pentagon yeah the one in Washington DC
cave describes the script as a stone
cold Masterpiece sure why not not over
yet it's been pretty quiet the past
decade but Ridley Scott still hasn't
given up on Gladiator in March of 2017
Scott said he does know how to bring him
back in reference to Maximus so never
give up right Maximus
wouldn't
not long after the Twilight Saga
concluded Summit entertainment geared up
for its next young adult franchise
Ender's Game based on the awon Scott
Card novel of the same name Ender's Game
was envisioned as the first in a series
of new Sci-Fi films after all there's a
ton of written material to draw from but
the series got canned long before its
completion here's why we never got to
see an Enders Game sequel box office
bomb Hollywood is a business people tend
to forget that sometimes Studio
Executives would love to make whatever
movies they want but they have to make
sure they'll make their money back and
then some so when Ender's Game grows to
Mere $1 125.5 million worldwide against
a production budget of $110 million that
showed Lion's gate that audiences
weren't willing to put up with an Enders
game franchise variety called it one of
the biggest bugs office bombs of the
year with that kind of response few
Studios would be willing to jump onto a
sequel boycott there are countless
reasons why a movie would flop at the
box office but for this particular film
an argument can be made that auson Scott
card's views on homosexuality and the
legalization of same-sex marriage led a
number of people especially those who
are on the fence about seeing Ender's
Game to boycott the movie Al together
it's impossible to say how much of an
impact the boycotts had on the movies
box office take but there's no denying
that in a politically charged climate
any negative press against a film like
Ender's Game couldn't have helped budget
constraints budget constraints are an
ordinary occurrence in Hollywood but
it's almost never a good thing thing
when it happened for instance the 20th
Century Fox kept the budget low for
James mangold's Logan because the
director and Hugh Jackman wanted the
film to be rated R while that ended up
working in their favor a studio usually
constrains a movie's budget if it
doesn't seem like the film will be as
successful as initially hoped that Rings
true for the wouldbe Enders Game sequel
the first movie had a production budget
of $110 million a fairly typical amount
for a sci-fi flick but the sequel might
have seen that number dip below the $100
million Mark director Gavin Hood
originally wanted to film the first and
second movies back to back but Lion's
gate wasn't up for that much of a gamble
had said it's a pity on many levels
because that cast was all there the sets
were all there we should have shot the
two movies back to back a tired Trend
before superhero movies fully took over
Hollywood each Studio was attempting to
launch its own young adult franchise to
snag some of the success of Twilight The
Hunger Games and Harry Potter some were
successful but most weren't and at this
point young adult adaptations are a
tired Trend that audiences no longer
seem interested in paying for Beautiful
Creatures flopped as did The Mortal
Instruments and even initially
successful ya franchises like the
Divergent series suffered insanely
diminishing returns young adult
adaptations can be successful if budgets
are kept low and if the movies are
marketed properly unfortunately every
Studio wants to believe they're sitting
on a gold mine so they go full steam
ahead with the first installment which
in the case of Ender's Game leaves
little room for expansion in the sequel
aged out as G had explained to hyperball
the proposed film sequel to Ender's Game
would have been based on Ender Shadow
which takes place concurrently with the
first book so if the studio really
wanted to adapt that story it would have
made more sense to film back to back as
Gavin Hood originally wanted to several
years have past and now Asa Butterfield
and Haley Steinfeld are far older than
their pre-teen characters in the books
Butterfield has starred in several other
young adult oriented movies such as Miss
perrin's Home for Peculiar Children and
the space between us while Steinfeld is
branching out in movies like The Pitch
Perfect series and the edge of 17 it
makes no sense to continue the series at
this stage then there are the bigger
actors like Harrison Ford Ben Kingsley
and Viola Davis with Ford returning to
his iconic characters in recent years he
would be a difficult person to nail down
for the young adult sequel to get all
these people together again would likely
require more money than Lion's gate
would be willing to cough up TV spin-off
even if Lion's gate and the cast were to
consider a sequel could the studio
afford it Hood made no secret about
having difficulties obtaining enough
money for end this game if he was having
trouble getting $110 million in 2013
he's not going to be able to get enough
money now and remember there are several
novels continuing in the story and even
more in the shadow and foric War series
with so much material the franchise
could work better as a television series
instead of a feature film franchise hey
it worked out pretty well for Game of
Thrones in fact shortly after the movie
released in theaters variety reported
that the studio was considering a TV
spin-off instead of a sequel since there
were issues getting the necessary money
for the first movie and it didn't do so
well at the box office it makes sense
for the studio to look at other options
unfortunately there haven't been any
updates on the TV front since that
report in 2013 so who knows if it'll
ever
happen Sinister is one of the better big
budget horror movies in recent memory
and nobody was surprised when this
blumhouse film got the sequel treatment
in 2015 but since then there hasn't been
so much as a whisper about a third
chapter instead it looks like the whole
Sinister Series has been abandoned in
favor of other franchises why does squel
happy Hollywood want nothing more to do
with Bou in his box of haunted videos
let's roll the tape Sinister 2 didn't
make enough cash producer Jason Blum
knows a thing or two about getting a
series off the ground he's the man who
made one-off movies like Paranormal
Activity Insidious in The Purge into
successful multi-film franchises but
when asked about the prospect of a third
Sinister movie during a Facebook live
chat in 2016 Blum was brutally honest
saying we didn't do well enough with
Sinister 2 not enough people went to see
Sinister 2 to make Sinister 3 which is
really sad if you're wondering what sad
looks like in terms of cold hard numbers
the original Sinister made 77 million on
a$3 million budget the sequel which cost
more than three times as much to make
brought in only 52 million critics tore
the second film apart so why did
audiences not latch on to Sinister 2 the
way they did for the original not to be
blunt but probably because it was a bad
movie at least according to critics
Wesley Morris of Grantland summed it up
best writing there comes a point when
you have to say no to these horror
sequels there's no skill or idea visible
anywhere just the sound of money being
sucked from your pockets and he wasn't
alone even critics who liked the first
Sinister movie thought this one was
cheap unbelievable and most of all
unnecessary the sequel botched the best
part like the first movie Sinister 2
centers around a series of snuff films
each involving the grizzly murder of
what appears to be an entire family and
in the first film these sequences were
so disturbing that it kind of felt like
we shouldn't even be seeing them which
made it a highly effective horror movie
if not the source of a few recurring
nightmares but in Sinister 2 the murder
films looked more like crudely shot be
movies screened with a Bargain Bin
horror soundtrack that took them over
the line from creepy to cheesy with the
scariest part of sinister effectively
ruined by the sequel It's no surprise
that Hollywood preferred not to unbox
any future home videos from boul they
killed the premise and the whole cast
after the original Sinister ended with a
huge reveal that the movie snuff films
were made by kids who killed their own
families while under the influence of an
ancient Boogeyman Sinister 2 tried to do
something different with the source of
the movie is no longer a mystery the
sequel took a new angle focusing on one
kid as he's courted by the ghostly Squad
of child murderers who want him to join
their ranks and taking all the mystery
out of the premise that made Sinister
scary in the first place oops on top of
that both of these movies end with the
deaths of virtually every major
character which is appropriately dark
for a horror film but not so good for a
horror franchise with nobody left alive
to star in a new installment Sinister 3
would have to start from scratch
creating a whole new set of characters
to breathe life into a tired storyline
the monster is a boore this is a problem
that started with Sinister and never got
fixed boul is more than just an
unpronouncable name he's a lousy
character too some cultures believed
that it lived in another realm reachable
only by ritual or sacrifice whatever
that means both movies identify boul
also known as the boogeyman as an
otherworldly being who exists to corrupt
innocent children but as the antagonist
of a major horror franchise we never
really get to know Bou his hopes his
dreams his reasons for dressing up like
a low rent Michael Jackson impersonator
sure he makes for a good jump scare but
without a compelling villain to shape
the franchise around making more
Sinister movies would be a chore
especially when competing series like
The Conjuring are trotting out fresh
interesting monsters with legitimate
backstories on the regular the original
director has moved on Sinister director
Scott derkson doesn't do generic horror
and he's especially good at translating
classic subject matter into something
freshly
[Applause]
terrifying you speak Latin huh that
would make him the perfect person to get
this spooky series back on track if only
he had the time for it but derkson led
someone else take the Reigns when it
came to directing Sinister 2 and by the
time the sequel hit theaters he was
already on to bigger things specifically
the Marvel movie Doctor Strange which
catapulted him into a whole new world of
big budget high-profile projects between
adapting bong Jun H Snowpiercer into a
TV series and probably helming the
inevitable Doctor Strange sequel derkson
has plenty on his plate and he isn't
likely to waste his energy trying to
bring small budget boul and his Squad of
killer kiddos back from the dead or
wherever they are so when it comes to
more Sinister sequels it looks like the
hero from Sinister 2 gets the last word
it's over
Zach you're now making him a
film based on the series of popular
Saturday Night Live sketches about
Metalhead Wayne cbell and his shy best
friend GTH 1992's Wayne's World was a
Smash Hit and a cultural phenomenon it
spawned catchphrases Galore Swing Swing
and put Queen's Bohemian raps CID back
on the pop charts the respectable ww 2
was released in 1993 and that was just
about it from Wayne and GTH will there
ever be a Wayne's World 3 here is an
extreme close-up on why it will never
happen get the net sequel slump
Paramount Pictures the studio behind
Wayne's World presumably lost a lot of
interest in a third installment after
taking a look at the box office receipts
for wsw 2 while it certainly has its
funny and memorable moments it didn't
quite capture the magic of the original
critics thought it was fine but not as
good as the first Way's world and it
only made $47 million at the domestic
box office which was far less impressive
than the originals $121 million
take no stairway denied it all added up
to a lack of evident demand for Wayne's
World 3 and Hollywood wasn't going to
put up the tens of millions of dollars
required to make it happen sister
slowdowns after the phenomenal success
of Wayne's World a slew of fulllength
movies based on Saturday Night Live
sketches and characters were released
and not one of them managed to come
anywhere near the box office bucks the
first ww earned Cone Heads It's Pat
Stewart saves his family Blues Brothers
2000 a KN at the Roxbury Superstar and
The Ladies Man were all SNL inspired
Duds that made a combined total of $111
million in theaters less than Wayne's
World amassed by itself the sub genre
died until 2010 when will Forte's Maca
send up mcgruber hit theaters and bombed
so overall there just hasn't been much
of a demand for movies based on sketches
people can watch at home for free and
that includes more weld getting busy the
the late '90s or early norts would have
been the right time to strike quickly
with another Wayne's World movie but
Mike Myers was simply too busy with
other projects after Way's World 2 Myers
regrouped and came up with another
over-the-top irresistible character
Austin Powers a British spy straight out
of a candy colored 60s British spy movie
yeah
baby the first movie in the series
Austin Powers international Man of
Mystery was a modest hit but built up
such a huge home video following that
the 199 9 sequel Austin Powers The Spy
Who shacked me made more than $200
million at the box office the third
movie 2002's Astin powers and gold
member did even better making those
movies along with voicing the main
character in the Shrek series and taking
roles in films like 54 and mystery
Alaska didn't leave a lot of time for
Myers to do much else Family Feud the
success of Austin Powers can be
partially blamed for why there was never
a third Way's world movie the character
of Dr Evil paraded several James Bond
villains particularly the similar
looking blow Feld of You Only Live Twice
But his clipped speaking voice distant
demeanor and some physical mannerisms
including extending his pinky finger
while talking may have also been
inspired by Dana carvey's around the
studio impression of their old SNL bus
Laur Michaels that thing yeah and then
you know when I saw Mike do it I did
kind of go that along with other issues
drove a wedge between the two actors who
didn't speak for years as a result of
their Tiff happily they've since made up
and have appeared at Wayne's World
screenings and on SNL together Health
matters Carvey wasn't physically
available to make ways World 3 when it
would have most logically entered
production sometime in the mid to late
'90s nor was he able to do much work at
all he had some major health problems
experiencing chest pains Carvey went to
a doctor where it was discovered that
blood wasn't properly flowing to his
heart hey come here come here look at
this x-ray your heart looks like a pig's
look at that thing Carvey underwent
several operations to correct the
disorder including a budget operation
where his doctor fixed the wrong artery
but has since made a full recovery not
interested probably the biggest reason
why Wayne's World 3 has never happened
is that Mike Myers doesn't seem to want
to do it all that much in 2008 Meers and
Dana Carvey appeared as Wayne and G at
the MTV Movie Awards leaving many fans
to wonder if a third big screen Ting was
in the offing but Maya said he did it
mainly to get caught up with his old
friend Carvey 3 years later Carvey host
did Saturday Night Live and brought in
Meers for a Wayne's World sketch that
reportedly sparked something in Meers
because in 2012 sources reported that
had written a screenplay for Wayne's
World 3 but Maya's team sent out a
notice to refute it all claiming he
hadn't completed a script nor was he
even working on one Myers and Carvey
played Wayne and GTH again for the SNL
40 special in 2015 it sparked movie
rumors that Meers good-naturedly
Shrugged off when asked by the Canadian
press if there were more waynew films in
the future he said was open to the idea
but that we shouldn't hold our breath
explaining it would be an interesting
examination of Wayne at 50 I don't know
what it would look like but the idea of
it makes me laugh and Dana and I had a
blast at the 40th anniversary so I don't
know
wory a walking nightmare and a machete
wielding killer clashed 20 years ago in
Freddy versus Jason and fans have been
begging for a sequel ever since here's
why it hasn't happened yet the nightmare
on Street and Friday the 13th franchises
were both popular profitable Series in
the ' 80s and '90s Freddy's last film
was almost a decade earlier and the
previous Jason flick had been a flop so
when Freddy versus Jason landed in 2003
combining them into a crossover film it
reenergized both characters and wound up
pulling in the highest box office grow
for both franchises with an estimated
$116 million Haul on a $3 million budget
it was a huge money maker and you'd
think that it would have led to a second
crossover un un fortunately attempts to
get a Freddy versus Jason sequel have
been stalled for years it wasn't helped
by the fact that both franchises opted
to reboot their respective series with a
new Friday the 13th arriving in 2009 and
a remake of Nightmare on Elm Street a
year later neither were successful
enough to Warrant follow-ups at the same
time the movie rites to Jason and the
Friday the 13th series was soon caught
in a complicated legal web that has
never been cleared up attempts to make a
sequel to Freddy versus Jason went
further than just pairing up the two
villains for a second bout however
looking for a fresh spin the studio
tried adding a third character and it
seems that they settled on one in
particular Ash Williams from Evil Dead
played by Bruce Campbell the chainsaw
wielding Warrior would have matched up
well against the machete and Claws of
Jason and Freddy the idea actually stems
from an Easter egg and Jason Goes to
Hell where a copy of the necro namicon
from Evil Dead is implied to be
responsible for Jason's power according
to a Sci-Fi interview with that film's
director Adam Marcus he was quote
setting up a mythology that Jason's mom
wanted to sum back so badly that she she
reads from the Necronomicon and brings
about the resurrection of her son as a
result the notion to cross all three
franchises together seemed like a
natural fit unfortunately getting the
rights to both Freddy and Jason was hard
enough but wrangling Evil Dead on top of
it proved nearly impossible Bruce
Campbell meanwhile wasn't all that
excited about the concept and eventually
he walked away he said on Reddit I'm not
real interested in crossovers one of the
main reasons why Ash versus Jason versus
Freddy did not come to pass is because
we couldn't control any other character
other than Ash that felt like a
creatively bankrupt way to go this guy's
behind everything wow there's an
overstatement say what as the rumors of
a three-way battle with Ash in a sequel
gain steam the film's director Ronnie U
addressed the gossip in 2004 speaking to
creature Corner about the possibility of
merging the three franchises he said
that's something that the studio came up
with they asked me and all the fans
wanted me to do it as well so I said yes
show me the script I would definitely do
it they're still working on the script I
haven't seen anything so sadly used jab
at the long development time was
frighteningly preent and nothing has yet
to come of it some 20 years later and
he's not the only one who's been
frustrated by the lack of movement the
original film's writers Damen Shannon
and Mark Swift are Still Holding Out for
a sequel to come to fruition in 2020
they tweeted we still want it to get
made as for the cast Freddy actor and
star Robert England expressed his regret
that they didn't do a sequel while
chatting with two Fab in 2020 he said I
think that remakes were rushed I know
the Remake on a Nightmare on Elm Street
was premature we should have done
another Freddy versus Jason film and
then waited they should have waited for
5 or 10 years as we've already discussed
one of the reasons the sequel hasn't
come yet is that both franchises have
since seen Clean Slate reboots new
actors were brought in with Jackie L
Haley putting on the Strip sweater to
play Freddy and future Swamp Thing actor
Derek M daing the hockey mask as Jason
though the 2009 version of Friday the
13th did okayish at the bugs office
neither film got a sequel of its own but
one of the ideas thrown around by fans
as to to essentially do what both
franchises did in 2003 they want to
create a crossover mashup movie to
re-energize both series at the same time
recent wild rumors and fans desires
aside there's some logic to the notion
even if it's unlikely that we get Ash
Williams a battle between the rebooted
Killers could be a winning idea with the
right script a solid director and
perhaps some Legacy actors from both
franchises returning to make a splash in
fact during a 2008 conversation with MTV
Derek M even said he'd love to do a
Freddy versus Jason sequel although at
at the time Jackie O Haley hadn't been
publicly announced for the nightmare
reboot yet and Ms was saying I would
love to throw down against Robert
England I have been away from my
children far too long and like most
sequels stuck in development hell we
know a lot about what the sequ to Freddy
versus Jason would have been about
that's because in 2004 Bloody Disgusting
actually published a screen treatment on
their website for all to see it was a
version that incorporated Ash Williams
and it begins where Army of Darkness and
Freddy versus Jason left left off Ash is
searching for the Necronomicon the town
of Crystal Lake has been redeveloped and
Jason's house where the book resides is
to be torn down according to the
treatment Freddy is clinging to life
inside Jason's mind and a film opens
with Lorie cbell and will Rollins
returning to Crystal Lake to make sure
both villains are truly dead after a
frightening quick kill sequence we meet
our heroes a group of teens working at a
new smart the store where ashworks buil
in the new Crystal Lake but when Jason
learns of the necron namicon he plans to
use it to free Freddy from his mind and
resurrect his mother he's not the only
one who knows the book is in Crystal
Lake though and Ash has arrived to find
it too leading him into a showdown with
both Freddy and Jason with the help of
his fellow smart employees ultimately
Freddy versus Jason versus Ash would
have turned the two villains into
reluctant allies or sending in Bruce
Campbell's Ash to stop them both
unfortunately one of the biggest reasons
that a sequel hasn't happened to this
point is that actor Robert England the
only man to portray Freddy Krueger until
2010 is no longer interested in playing
the character I won't Dan the Fedora or
strap on the claws again because uh I'm
just a little too old England doubled
down on this in 2023 telling variety I'm
too old and thick to play Freddy now I
just can't do fight scenes for more than
one take anymore I've got a bad neck and
bad back and arthritis in my right wrist
so I have to hang it up but I love to
Cameo however the horror actor did
suggest that Kevin Bacon might make for
a good Freddy saying the way he moves
might be perfect for the part with all
that said however if the screen
treatment that have been leaked by
Bloody Disgusting had ever been made we
know it would have starred England and
Bruce Campbell as well as Monica kenina
and Jason rter returning as survivors
Lori and will Kina even addressed the
possibility recently while talking with
the podcast happy horror time revealing
that both she and R had options for a
sequel in their contract for the first
film of course it's also likely that Ken
kinger would have reprised his role as
Jason 2 and he may even still be up for
a return if somehow a Freddy versus
Jason follow-up could ever be made he
made this clear during an appearance at
a panel during The Spook Cara horror
convention in 2022 saying if they ask me
to do that I'd be very happy to come
back it's been two decades since Freddy
versus Jason first at theaters but what
you might not know is that there is
indeed a continuation of the story just
not on film The Crossover sequel took
place in comic book form a joint
production between DC Comics imprint
Wild Storm and New Jersey based
independent publisher Dynamite
entertainment titled Freddy versus Jason
versus Ash the six isue miniseries was
published in 2007 and written by James
koric from a Story by Jeff Catz the
writer of the planned movie following
that original treatment more or less the
story sees Freddy resurrected by Jason
through the use of the Necronomicon at
the same time Ash Williams arrives in
Crystal Lake looking for the cursed book
and an epic battle ensues with Freddy
resurrecting all of Jason's previous
victims as deadites or ashm slay but
what makes this sequel so unique is that
it even received a sequel of its own
Freddy versus Jason versus Ash the
nightmare Warriors published in 2009 and
once again written by koric based on a
story from cats this time around the US
government tries to control Freddy and
Jason's powers only to unleash them once
again on an unsuspecting populace then
it's up to W to join forces with former
survivors of both Madmen to bring them
down and save the world given that
Freddy versus Jason brought together two
iconic horror franchises it makes sense
that it amassed a bigger audience than
either had achieved alone even after 20
years of frustration fans are still
hoping that they'll finally get a chance
to see Freddy and Jason together again
the only thing to
fear is fear
himself over on change.org a petition to
get a Freddy versus Jason sequel
collected signatures from thousands of
supporters who were hoping to get
Hollywood's attention while nothing came
of it it did show just how passionate
the movies fans are likewise over on
Reddit Freddy versus Jason versus Ash
often pops up in discussions of horror
sequels fans still want to see and it
remains a hot topic of conversation to
this day even the Press is still in love
with articles podcasts and websites
continuing to publish discussions that
Ponder the possibilities of a part to
even decades later there are many
challenges to overcome to make a Freddy
versus Jason sequel happen a new story
and script will have to be assembled
given Bruce Campbell's disin in a
crossover and Robert England will have
to be convinced to return or be replaced
by a new Freddy the legal rights to the
Friday the 13 series will have to be
cleared up which is no easy feat while
the shudio will have to be convinced
that such a crossover 20 years later can
still work but even with all that in
mind there's definitely a way it can
happen when it comes to the legal
problems shudos have shown that there's
money to be made and a blockbuster to be
produced there's not much they won't do
to get the rights they need to make it
happen for proof look no further than
Sony's unprecedent to deal with Marvel
to incorporate Spider-Man into the MCU
we admit it's probably a long shot with
everything that's working against it but
it's what the fans clearly crave and
with Crossovers and cinematic universes
All the Rage it could stand to make big
box office
bucks there have to be more tombs out
there in need of raiding so why didn't
2018s Tomb Raider ever lead to another
Adventure you can thank Amazon for that
Tomb Raider was one of the hottest video
game series of the 1990s centering on
Laura crof A Relic hunting Adventurer
the first film adaptation of the Tomb
Raider franchise was Angelina Jolie's
2001 Adventure Fleck it earned a healthy
$273 million at the box office a solid
take for a turn of the Millennium action
movie and enough to get a sequel quickly
green lit in 2018 the Baton was passed
to IA vander's Tomb Raider reboot and it
earned almost the exact same amount yet
there's been no followup since but the
reason why is more complicated than
ticket sales a sequel was in the works
for a 2021 release but it quickly hit a
snag with the outbreak of covid-19 and
early 2020 just as things were
apparently ramping up the cander was
repeatedly asked about the sequel and in
a chat with collider in 2021 she seemed
unsure if it was still going to happen
explaining preo I would have said said
yes and now I think it's a yes still
it's not green lit but the script is in
the making and I think everyone is
excited and I would love to revisit Lara
again those delays may have cost them a
sequel because in 2022 Amazon acquired
MGM which forced the franchise into a
complicated legal limbo and the rights
lapsed an anonymous Studio source told
the rap there was a pre-negotiated
ticking clock that had been agreed to
and there was no way to rescue it in
time MGM asked the right holders for
more time but their patients had run out
even though Tomb Raider was met with
decidedly mixed reviews upon its release
it has achieved a mild cult status with
fans who would love to see theander back
as Laura Croft in a second movie and it
seems the filmmakers and its cast would
love nothing more than to reunite for
another go in 2021 Lovecraft country
Creator Misha green signed up to write
and direct a sequel howdy Tomb Raider
fans my name is Misha green and I'm the
writer director of the upcoming Tomb
Raider movie The cander seemed
particularly pumped about the prospect
of working with her telling
Entertainment Weekly in 2021 I hope we
go and make another movie because of the
pandemic we had plans of shooting this
film and now it's been 1 and 1/2 years
but Mesa green is on board and she's
riding a draft right now ever hopeful
theander seemed ready to strap on the
guns and get back to adventuring adding
it would be so amazing if we get to go
and do this very big ass film together
going to kick some ass in front of the
camera and behind the camera a year
later though the kander's tone shifted
and she cautioned that the odds were
stacked against them telling movie Zen
in 2022 I'm good at going back to that
role and it would mean a lot of training
now it's a lot of talk considering that
Amazon has bought MGM and after the
pandemic there is so much politics so
right now I actually do not really know
what is happening if there's going to be
a Tomb Raider sequel it would of course
have to star Alicia bander as far far
back as 2019 with the sequel already in
early development there wasn't actually
concrete word on whether Vander would
reprise the role with people reporting
that it was still unclear whether she'd
be back but that question was answered
when the actress officially signed up
and she began speaking about the sequel
publicly sadly most of her comments were
regarding its long delay Beyond viander
there isn't much known about who else
from the cast might have reappeared in
this proposed sequel though an
unverified report in 202 did suggest
that Kristen Scott Thomas would return
and that she'd have a much metor role
the actress had played a smaller part as
Anna Miller Lara's mentor and a
colleague of her father in the 2018 film
Anna is a bigger bad in the video games
and according to the rumor she would
have been bumped up to the main villain
for the sequel which had been teased at
the close of the first film you can pick
up where he left off Tomb Raider was
helmed in 2018 by a relatively unknown
Norwegian filmmaker named Roar utok who
a few years later directed The Cult hit
troll the script was penned by Geneva
Robertson dwar in her feature film debut
alongside co-writers Evan Dy and
Alistair sens Roberts and dwar went on
to work on Captain Marvel but neither
She nor utog were expected to return for
the second Tomb Raider film after it
began development instead writer Amy
jump was signed in 2019 to pin the
second film and Ben Wheatley Inked a
deal to sit in the director's chair but
as the delays on the film began to pile
up the studio made significant changes
to the crew behind the camera which saw
both Amy jump and Ben Wheatley dismissed
from the project replacing them was
Misha green who was announced to both
write and direct the sequel in 2021
though no reason was given as to the
swamp in filmmakers nevertheless green
got right to work and by may she was
telling her following on Twitter that
the first draft of the script was
complete but that there was still a long
journey to production long in this
instance was a hell of an understatement
you might as well tie a stone to your
foot and jump off the boat now though it
took more than a year after Tomb Raider
was released before the studio was ready
to commit to a sequel they finally did
put the Wheels in Motion in 2019 in fact
rumor has it that the Tomb Raider sequel
came fairly close to beginning
production a November 2019 report from
hn entertainment claimed that viander
was signed on the script was ready to go
and the studio was locking down
locations for shooting per that same
report which was seemingly never
confirmed by any of the major trades MGM
Studios Was preparing to bring the
production back to the UK where much of
the first movie was filmed Warner
Brothers leaves in studios was even said
to be the place where they would set up
shop for the sequel before it all fell
apart what's known for a fact is that
this version of the movie was supposed
to start shooting in early 2020 although
pandemic related shutdowns forced the
project to be put on hold and then its
release date was taken off the calendar
altogether it wouldn't be until 2021
that it got back up and running by then
green was the writer and director of
record and her version of the film was
also further along than some fans May
realize as it happens it even had a
title Tomb Raider obsidian and viander
was expressing excitement over an
imminent production start that never
came nobody but those involved know what
the sequel would have been about when it
was under the stewardship of writer jump
and director Ben Wheatley however some
word has trickled out over the years of
what might have happened in the version
written by Green cobbled together from
various tidbits that leaked during its
development and after the film was
shuttered in addition to talk that
Kristen Scott Thomas would return in a
bigger role as the main villain of the
film audiences also got a brief glimpse
of some of the action in late 2022 when
storyboard artist Jake Lunt Davies
posted a series of images that he'
created for the project on Twitter what
they revealed didn't give away too much
of the plot but they did showcase a
pulse pounding sequence that may have
kicked off the story with a daring
attack on Croft Manor carried out by
shadowy agents given the ending of the
2018 Tomb Raider and the rumored larger
role for Anna Williams it's possible
this raid was orchestrated by Laura
croft's Mentor sparking a quest that
would take her to various locations to
get to the truth if there's anything
still standing in the way of a direct
sequel to 2018 Tomb Raider it isn't the
pandemic problems with the script or
scheduling with the actors instead it's
the fact that a reboot to the franchise
was announced in early 2023 this stems
from mgm's loss of the rights following
their acquisition by Amazon with an
apparent bidding war taking place for
the chance start from scratch
Blockbuster news shaking Hollywood this
morning Amazon buying MGM Studios for
8.5 billion bucks the winners of that
bidding war were of course Amazon who
quickly announced Grand plans for a
total reboot of the movie with a new
actor taking over for theander the deal
was a big one for the streaming service
which includes much more than just the
rights to make a feature film and while
numbers weren't announced The Hollywood
Reporter suggested it only fell a little
short of their gargantuan deal for the
Lord of the Rings the announcement came
on the heels of the news that Amazon
would be getting into the video game
publishing business and it would be
putting out the next Tomb Raider console
game from developer Crystal Dynamics
details at this time are still scetchy
with no writer announced for the film
let alone a director or Star but that
doesn't mean that Amazon hasn't started
work on the project and they have in
fact made bigger plans that could see an
explosion of Tomb Raider across multiple
media platforms after snagging the
rights to a Tomb Raider adaptation the
folks at Amazon have revealed they'll be
crafting a big screen reboot but that
isn't all the film will be just one part
of a larger tapestry and they have plans
to turn the franchise into a
full-fledged Cinematic Universe to make
that happen they have announced that a
Tomb Raider TV series is in the works as
a streaming original with plans for the
show and film to be tightly integrated
with both each other and the already
announced video game relaunch even more
exciting is that spearheading the effort
behind the scenes will be Phoebe Waller
Bridge the three-time anyy award-winning
Creator and writer of flea bag star of
Indiana Jones and the DI of Destiny and
co-writer of the 2021 James Bond film no
time to die according to the trade
Waller bridge will write the series but
is unlikely to be involved in the film
and while many fans may have jumped to
the conclusion that she might play Laura
Croft 2 that doesn't appear to be the
case one actor who has stepped up to
volunteer for the title role is Michaela
J Rodriguez who told variety I would
like to tackle a rooll like Laura crof I
would love to do that because I have the
badassness and sex appe appeal to make
people love it if not I would also love
to be Laura croft's right-hand girl who
gets just as much airtime and is right
next to her killing it with a Cinematic
Universe on its way that will reboot the
franchise with an all new cast and crew
it might seem like a sequel to 2018s
Tomb Raider has no chance of ever seeing
the light of day but if one steps back
and takes stock of the Hollywood
landscape they'll see that a return to
that Universe isn't really far-fetched
and it could actually still happen even
if it's not any time soon after all
recent films like Spider-Man no way home
and the Flash have seen the return of
actors who audiences thought they've
said goodbye two decades ago with both
Toby Maguire and Michael Keaton
returning as Spider-Man and Batman
versus Angelina jool Lee that would be a
cool film and while there's very very
little chance that Amazon would use a
Multiverse gimmick to have previous Lura
croft's meet although that's what
Studios all seem to think the fans want
the idea of returning to the continuity
of a previous movie even after a reboot
isn't without precedent itself the
Terminator and Halloween franchises V
did just that after all from the sounds
of it even star Alicia Vander would
still be up for reprising the role years
down the line theander Variety in 2023
for me that was another one of those
childhood dreams to portray an action
character was awesome and Beyond what I
ever thought I would do and I think the
physical part is something that I really
enjoyed so yeah if another opportunity
like that game again I'll be
interested okay so maybe we'll never get
to see Galaxy Quest 2 but by grabthar's
hammer it will be Avenged Galaxy Quest
is a rare breed of cold classic Sci-fi
comedy one that still holds up more than
20 years after its release David mammed
for instance famously included it
alongside the Godfather and A Place in
the Sun that's one of the only Flawless
movies in existence even the most
obvious targets of his biting sat Tire
hold the film in high Este steam George
teay once called it a powerful piece of
documentary film making and Patrick
Stewart claimed no one laughed louder or
longer in the cinema than I
did well the film didn't quite set any
box office records earning around $90
million on a $45 million budget it spent
the next couple of decades picking up
momentum becoming a staple in every
nerd's Blu-ray collection considering
that Hollywood has developed a Perma
crush on the soldier based sequels
Galaxy Quest seems like Prime real
estate for a reboot remake or re
something asked by MTV News whether or
not they'd come back for another round
soie Weaver pointed out that she still
has her costume while Sam Rockwell
simply said yeah even Tim Alam was
pitching story
ideas your commander is UND deck so why
haven't we been back to the nsea
protector since 1999 the answer sadly is
that we've come close more than once but
a Confluence of bad luck has kept Galaxy
Quest 2 from reaching our screens here's
how it went down by 2015 Galaxy Quest
had firmly cemented its place in popular
culture and interested part he started
priming the pump for another Go Round
The idea was actually to create a
streaming series as a followup to the
original film it was reported at the
time that Amazon Studios have begun
develop on the project in conjunction
with Paramount the show was even green
lits directly to series suggesting that
it was at one point a sure thing by grab
thar's
Hammer what a savings these plans were
shortlived however as in January of 2016
Galaxy Quest star Alan Rickman died at
age 69 from pancreatic cancer some
Rockwell saw this along with Tim Allen's
difficult to pass availability as a
death nail for the project then in 2017
deadline reported that Amazon was still
developing the series with Paul Shia on
board as head writer The Show Must Go
[Music]
On Dam you this Incarnation was po to
what was initially supposed to be a year
reportedly the result of Paramount TV
president Amy Powell's exit from her
post word of a potential sequel
eventually resurfaced in January of 2021
when Tim Allen stated that a new entry
in the series was effectively in limbo
he Tau Entertainment Weekly we talk
about it all the time there is
constantly a little flicker of bhane
torch that we could reboot it with
translation never give up never
surrender on April 18th 2023 Paramount
plus announced that a new Galaxy Quest
TV series is currently in the works for
the streaming service however it has yet
to be confirmed whether this new show
will reboot the original film story or
serve as a long long awaited sequel to
The Landmark sci-fi comedy currently the
only name attached to this new version
of Galaxy Quest is Mark Johnson who
worked as a producer on the prior film
and will likewise produce this upcoming
project for what it's worth Tim Allen
told comicbook.com about a Galaxy Quest
2 script he believed could still see the
light of day as recently as November of
2022 nevertheless with details on his
new show so scarce it remains unclear if
Paramount plus is finally realizing
alen's vision for a sequel or taking the
franchise in a different direction
entirely a Coming of Age movie with the
superhero twist Skyhigh left the lasting
impression on both kids and former kids
so why has a sequel never seen the light
of
day debuting in theaters the same year
as Batman Begins and one year after
Spider-Man 2 Skyhigh was poised to
become as big a blockbuster as either of
those other films Disney still years
away from purchasing comic book
Juggernaut Marvel May even have been
banking on it but when it arrived it
wasn't the Smash Hit Studio execs were
hoping for this is so unfair if life
were suddenly get there I doubt it would
happen in high school while the film did
more than double its modest budget it
didn't crack $100 million worldwide that
left Hollywood cool on the idea of a
sequel and since then the cast and crew
have gone on to have bigger more
prosperous careers Kurt Russell has made
a Resurgence largely thanks to his role
in Quinton Tarantino's the hateful while
Mary Elizabeth Winstead became a star
thanks to 2010's Scott Pilgrim versus
the world on television Daniel Panabaker
became a different superhero on the CWS
The Flash while Nicholas Brun garnered a
pair of Emmy nominations thanks to his
role in the HBO drama succession getting
the gang back together may not be such
an easy feat but there have been plenty
of rumors over the years implying that
such an event could still
happen just because Sky High wasn't a
huge box office success doesn't mean
that it has no di hard fans on the
contrary it's managed to develop a fan
base containing both comic book fans and
Disney lovers and those involved with
the film continue to be asked about the
possibility of more stories set in its
Universe to this very Day in 2020 writer
Mark mccorkel who is also the co-creator
of Koss and has since written The
Penguins of Madagascar and Big Hero 6
the series spoke about a potential
followup to the 2005 film he told
inverse over the years we always thought
maybe a sequel could happen one of these
days there was always a belief that this
was a rich enough world to keep going
with new ideas I guess if the film still
has that same affection of people
watching it and streaming It on Disney
plus who knows maybe if the people speak
their wishes will be answered mccorkel
isn't the only one hoping for Skyhigh 2
Daniel Panabaker who portrayed the
plant-loving pacifist Lea told the
international business times in 2018 I
would do anything to make another one
Mary Elizabeth Winstead who played the
Techno baby themed super villain royal
pain doesn't seem to think her story is
over either when asked about the
character's future on the ladies night
podcast she said I think she's still
operating as a super villain for sure I
don't think there was any moral
reassessment for her actions Winstead
even joked that instead of reverting
everyone back into babies royal pain
would spend the sequel turning innocent
students into senior citizens patience
we've waited this long when the time is
right we'll have our revenge with so
many years having passed since Sky High
was in theaters it's fair to ask who
would actually return if a sequel was
greenlit while not everyone has directly
addressed their possible return there
are a few who have and thankfully
Michael angarano is one of them angarano
who played lead character Will
Stronghold told ultimate Disney not long
after the first film's release I would
be up for a sequel for sure especially
if everyone from this film was also
involved but would everyone else be
involved Daniel Panabaker seems to think
so based on comments she made in 2018
she elaborated I just saw Nick Braun and
Michael angarano at a party in LA and I
love those boys so much I would see Mary
Elizabeth Winstead when we were both
working in Vancouver I think it would be
great and I think we would all jump at
the opportunity the students of Skyhigh
aren't the only ones interested in
continuing The Story actor Kevin Hein
who played bus driver Ron Wilson was
quick to affirm that he would absolutely
return for a sequel at a press junket
for another film he gushed I would love
to I mean that cast the cast is amazing
the array of people in that cast is
phenomenal even though there's been no
concrete talk of a Sky High sequel since
the first movie was released that
doesn't mean that those involved haven't
had ideas regarding where the story
should go in 2019 director Mike Mitchell
opened up about his concept for Sky High
2 including a proposed title Mitchell
told I9 I am hugely proud of it and they
should make it a franchise we have a
whole sequel that's called save you or
save University from the sounds of it
the sequel would have sent the young
Heroes off to to college where they
surely would have met even more young
men and women training to become the
world's next Defenders of humanity
Mitchell isn't the only one with fun
ideas of where the story could go more
recently Daniel Panabaker shared her
thoughts on a different story one that
takes into account the long amount of
time that has passed since the first
movie She elaborated I'd like to think
that maybe their teachers at Sky High
because it's been long enough that they
could go back and teach they could be
the young cool hip teachers and then
they're teaching the next class of
superheroes with efforts to get a
cinematic sequel to Skyhigh having
stalled for years it's worth asking if
the creators should be looking at other
ways to bring a follow-up to life while
they could continue the story in comic
form the way shows like Smallville and
Firefly have they could also opt for
television that was apparently once on
the drawing board as director Mike
Mitchell revealed during an interview
with Gizmodo in 2019 according to the
filmmaker the studio originally had
bigger plans than just movies as he
explained except for Kurt Russell and
Kelly Preston every actor signed a
contract to make it into a TV show it's
nice to know that whatever happens to me
you'll still be around to save the
world looking forward to it Disney
presumably wanted Skyhigh to become a TV
hit on their very own Disney Channel led
by the young cast rather than pricier
big screen Stars however the movie's
unremarkable performance at the box
office left it overshadowed by other
family films like March of the Penguins
and Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
could a TV sequel still materialize
Mitchell isn't sure but he's totally on
board and just waiting for Disney to
give the word he joked dude I'm ready to
go it's up to you in the media just
write that it's
happening it's been a long time since
2005 and the Disney Channel along with
pretty much every other cable network is
far from the Juggernaut it once was that
hasn't stopped the massive company from
producing plenty of content for their
streaming service Disney plus and the
service might just be the perfect home
for a Skyhigh sequel writer Mark MC corl
certainly thinks so he told inverse in
2020 to me it's a very natural fit for
Disney plus and over the years we always
thought maybe a sequel could happen one
of these days that interview immediately
sparked wild speculation that Disney was
developing a Sky High sequel project for
the streaming service even though
nothing was ever confirmed and the
rumors are still nothing more than
rumors it's not hard to imagine skyh
High becoming a Disney plus feature film
series or episodic Adventure it could
all happen on a relatively modest budget
and would surely attract plenty of
longtime
fans it may not have attracted lines of
people around the block but Sky High has
become beloved by Disney fans for its
bright cheery tone and colorful
family-friendly action though many years
have passed since the movie was released
enthusiasm for it and a possible sequel
has never waned on websites like Reddit
and Twitter fans of the original film
Express their love and call for a sequel
nearly to decades later in 2020 a
petition to get a sequel up and running
cropped up complete with an idea on what
it could be about the fan proposed 2020
marks the 15-year anniversary of the
release of this Smash Hit And we propose
that the original cast and creators of
Skyhigh reunite for a sequel depicting a
high school reunion featuring the
characters we have all adored for well
over a decade even though the petition
didn't Garner as much support as other
fand driven attempts to get movies made
have its mere existence demonstrates
just how passionate Sky High fans are
when life gives you
lemons make apple juice
[Music]
I can't make lemons I don't know what it
is Sky High may have been a little too
far ahead of its time striking when
colorful superheroes were on their way
out and darker grittier superheroes were
on their way in it missed the era of the
Cinematic Universe by a few years too
meaning that some may think that
audiences have no interest in a sky-
high sequel nowadays but there's more
reason to believe that the world needs a
sky- high sequel now more than ever in
the last decade superhero movies from
Marvel and DC have got gotten almost too
popular for their own good reaching a
critical mass that has seen some
audiences souring on their latest
offerings Marvel is engulfed in a
complicated Multiverse story and their
latest entries have been met with
lackluster reception meanwhile things
got so bad for DC that they decided to
reboot their Cinematic Universe entirely
both have become so overr that at times
it feels like all the fun has been
sucked out of them a Sky High sequel
could be just the antidote as Mike
mccorkel said Mike had a vision of
bright colors and it being friendly and
upbeat Sky High proved that you can be
bright and colorful and still resonate
with real human emotions a throwback to
a simpler era a Sky High sequel could be
the hopeful optimistic family-friendly
superhero adventure that the movies have
been
missing from a sudden car accident to a
disgraced Hollywood producer there are
several shocking reasons why Kill Bill
Volume 3 never materialized and why
there's a good chance it never will Kill
Bill volume 1 is the only one of Quenton
Tarantino's movies to get a sequel so
why isn't it received a threequel if
you're looking for a simple answer it's
that Tarantino is waiting for his stars
to grow up a bit from the very beginning
Tarantino has said that his plan for a
potential volume 3 requires the actors
from the original films to be at least
15 years older not just the adults like
Uma Thurman and Daryl Hannah but also
child actors peara Haney Hardin and
Ambrosia Kelly the longer and more
complicated answers that Tarantino style
has evolved over the last two decades
and the projects he's made more recently
look very different from Kill Bill death
Pro part of the 2007 double feature
experiment Grindhouse was the last of
his films to have a certain Kill Bill
Vibe mostly due to the performance of
Thurman stunt double Zoe Bell as a
fictionalized version of herself from
2009 onward however he moved forward
with a very different series of Revenge
films rewriting historical atrocities
with in glorious bastards D Jango
Unchained and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood a focus on the literary rather
than the Visionary has consumed
Tarantino's output in the last decade
from the drawing room drama of the
hateful Aid to his novelization of Once
Upon a Time in H Hollywood as his
self-imposed career clock is ticking
down it seems a strong possibility that
another Kill Bill sequel just isn't
something that interests Tarantino very
much anymore journalists have been
asking Quenton Tarantino about a
possible volume 3 for two decades and
the famously Gabby director has happily
obliged and gleefully fueled the rumors
in 2004 he referred to the possible
series as his take on Sergio Leon's
dollars Trilogy and claimed that his
initial plan was to make a sequel every
10 years once 10 years had actually
passed though things had changed while
promoting the hateful a in 2015
Tarantino told variety I'm not
committing to it but I wouldn't be
surprised if the Bride made one more
appearance before the whole thing is
said and done Tarantino has also
repeatedly stated that he will direct
only 10 films once he completes that
10th and final film he will apparently
retire from making movies with every new
release in the last few years he's
gotten closer to that self-imposed cuto
and unless he breaks his vow or finds a
loophole it looks less and less likely
that Kill Bill Volume 3 will be included
in his filmography the Kill Bill films
are all about revenge and they center
around an important ethical question is
a desire to seek retribution to finish
unfinished business ever Justified or
merely a justification berrix kiddo sets
out to destroy the people who destroyed
her life but she kills an awful lot of
other people along the way Bill even
calls her out on it during their final
confrontation all those people you
killed to get to me felt damn good
didn't
they yes the bride slice through dozens
of Oran isi's bodyguards not for some
high-minded Act of cosmic balance but
because she enjoyed doing it according
to Tarantino a third film would pick up
the Revenge theme for a new generation
Nikki Bell daughter of former deadly
Viper assassination Squad member verita
green seeks revenge against the bride
for the death of her mother raised and
trained by the treacherous Sophie fatal
whom Beatrix left maimed but alive Nikki
would set out for her own righteous
Vengeance facing the bride along with
her now grown daughter B kiddo you can
take my word for
it your mother had it coming back in
2007 series producer E Bennett Walsh
told the audience at the Shanghai Film
Festival that the third and potentially
fourth film might also feature a pair of
former henchmen from the first movie
seeking their own revenge against the
bride the first two Kill Bill films
leave precious few characters Alive by
the end but there are few actors that
would be expected to return in a
follow-up first and foremost of course
is Beatrix kiddo herself Uma Thurman
Julie drus could also return as Sophia
fatal as well as Daryl hannnah as the
bride's Nemesis Ellie driver left
blinded but alive at the end of Kill
Bill too several actors from the films
have sadly died in the last two decades
including David kerine and sunny Chiba
the real question is who would play the
now grown BB and Nikki Part of Quenton
Tarantino's plan to wait 15 years was to
give actor Ambrosia Kelly time to grow
up in 2004 he told Entertainment Weekly
it's exciting to know that somewhere
there's a little girl who will grow up
to be my Leading Lady however Kelly
hasn't acted on screen since 2012 and in
2023 Viva a fox said in an interview
with variety that her dream casting for
the role of Nikki would be Z DEA as for
BB pearah Haney Hardin remains active in
the business and even had a small role
in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood in
recent years though a different
candidate has emerged thera's real life
daughter Maya Hawk who's become a star
in her own right Quenton Tarantino has
developed a routine company of sorts
over the years and for a while Uma
Thurman was not just a company player
but amus and collaborator of the
director the two of them developed the
character of the Bride while working
together on pul fiction after all the
deadly Viper assassination Squad sounds
an awful lot like the crime fighting
team in Mia Wallace's TV pilot Fox Force
5 fox is in we a bunch of Foxy chicks
force is in we a force to be reckoned
with and five is in this 1 2 3 4 five of
us however Thurman and Tarantino have
not worked together since Kill Bill
volume 2 came out in 2004 and more than
a decade later one of the possible
reasons why came to light in a 2018
profile in the New York Times Thurman
stated that Tarantino had coerced her
into doing an unauthorized automobile
stunt instructed to drive a convertible
down a winding path in Mexico at 40 mph
the Thurman lost control of the car and
ran off the side of the road resulting
in a concussion and damage to her knees
footage of the accident was released
online after the story dropped footage
which according to Thurman Tarantino had
fought for years to keep private in an
Instagram post accompanying the profile
Thurman acknowledged that Tarantino
finally allowed her to release the
footage and said that he feels
remorseful about the incident even after
making amends personally the two have
yet to collaborate again in the
Instagram post featuring footage of Uma
Thurman's rack she wrote that while she
feels the negligent stunt itself was not
done with malicious intent the 15-year
coverup of the accident very much was an
act of malice Thurman laid the blame not
at Quenton Tarantino but squarely at the
feet of producers Lawrence Bender E
Bennett Walsh and Harvey Weinstein that
wasn't the only thing she accused
Weinstein of either in the 2018 New York
Times profile Thurman claimed that
Weinstein sexually assaulted her on two
different occasions in the 9s and he
threatened to end her career when she
confronted him over his actions she
wasn't the only one as other
high-profile stars like mea svino and
Selma hyek also shared their heroine
stories with the powerful producer
Weinstein ran the Disney Affiliated
Indie distributor Miramax and not only
produced both Kill Bill movies but
championed and nurtured Tarantino's
career from the very beginning in return
Tarantino's Works helped turn Miramax
and Weinstein himself into a Hollywood
power player and a household name
Tarantino worked with Weinstein on every
one of his films from Reservoir Dogs to
the hateful eights in 2015 and even
though he has since distanced himself
from the disgraced executive their
longtime friendship cast a shadow over
much of Tarantino's work Hill Bill
Volume 3 isn't the the only long awaited
Kill Bill project that may never see the
light of day the official narrative from
Mirror Max and Quenton tantino has
always been that the two Kill Bill films
were originally intended to be a single
4-Hour movie but it was split into two
volumes in order to improve its chances
at the box office that may or may not be
true after all the two films are very
different from each other in style and
other than Uma Thurman they have largely
different casts the idea that they were
ever meant to form one coherent film is
slightly dubious but nevertheless
Tarantino has dangled the possibility of
a combined feature called the whole
bloody Affair for years as of 2023 there
have only been two confirmed public
screenings of the whole bloody Affair
one was at the can film festival in 2004
and the other was a two-e run in 2011 at
the New Beverly Cinema the Los Angeles
theater owned by Tarantino reports from
those screenings confirm that the
combined feature runs mostly the same as
what the rest of the world already saw
but with a few differences the epic
fight between the bride and the Crazy 88
gang is presented entirely in color and
certain key scenes and lines have been
cut despite these tantalizing details
the there appear to be no plans to
release it publicly again in theaters or
on Blu-ray and streaming in March 2023
Quenton Tarantino announced his next
film the movie critic a 70 set drama
about you guessed it a movie critic when
the movie critic comes out it will be
Tarantino's 10th film and his film
career is supposedly finished after that
if the director follows through that
means lights out for Kill Bill Volume 3
Tarantino reinforced this idea in July
20123 while doing an interview with the
Flemish newspaper de Morgan when asked
if Maya Hawk could play the bride's
daughter in a third Kill Bill film The
aour replied I don't see that my last
film was about a film critic a male
critic and he plays in the 70s if you're
looking for the last word on the subject
that seems pretty final however don't
give up all hope just yet isuma Thurman
raised an intriguing possibility when
she was asked about it in 2022 she told
Fox 5 New York all I know is he's always
said he's going to make 10 but it
doesn't include if he does television
good volume 3 show up as a streaming
series at some point like Tarantino's
expansion of the hateful 8 for Netflix
in 2019 we'll just have to wait and see
whether or not he's decided to pull a
little trick on his fans silly
rabbit tricks are for kids even though
rumors have circulated since 2004 it's
been years since Kill Bill Volume 3 has
had any significant movement maybe we
actually will see it on the big or small
screen at some point with aged up Stars
peara Haney Hardin and Ambrosia Kelly or
maybe Maya Hawkins and DEA and each
other's throats only time will tell at
this point but if the project never
comes to pass it will at least be in
good company ter artino seems to enjoy
talking about films he will never make
as much as actually making films and the
last three decades are littered with
wouldbe features that never grew Beyond
his imagination for every in glorious
bastards there's a double v Vega which
would have brought together John
Travolta and Michael Madson as their
well-dressed Pulp Fiction and Reservoir
Dogs characters for every once upon a
time in Hollywood there is a 60 set
Casino Royale or an R-rated Star Trek
sequel that Sparks speculation and
excitement before fizzling and fading
away as he goes in a New Direction Hill
Bill Volume 3 may only ever exist in our
imagin ations but if it does happen
Against All Odds we know it'll be a
bloody good
time you'll Flo too or will you nobody
really knows whether we'll ever get to
see its chapter 3 but it's not looking
great here's why since franchise
potential is everything these days many
filmmakers end their stories with a hint
that audiences might one day return to
that world however it chapter 2 stays
largely faithful to the source material
Stephen King wrote the novel as a
standalone story with a defin intive
beginning middle and end on the it film
series respects these main beats even if
it takes creative Liberties in other
sections in the ends the losers perform
a ritual and tear out Penny wise's heart
Bringing Down the curtain on the Unholy
Clown's reign of terror their Victory
isn't without a cost though since Eddie
dies of his wounds in the final battle
while the friends lost Stan early in the
film in the book a devastating storm
watches over Derry but this event is
missing from the movie leaving the
audience with a more hopeful end to the
story look looking at the narrative from
an objective point of view the story of
it is over after chapter 2 these
characters have suffered overcome and
prevailed after all is said and done
ultimately they have arrived at their
final destination while it might be
tempting to start a new journey in it
chapter 3 that needs to be a truly
compelling reason to revisit Derry and
revive Pennywise especially after he
suffered such a final end while it isn't
unusual for different directors to helm
various installments in the trilogy it
chapter 3 wouldn't feel the same without
Andy mus Yeti his vision for the series
is unique and his signature horror style
can be felt in every part of the movies
to replace him would be akin to
replacing the very soul of the film
franchise unfortunately musetti has
never seen it as a three-film franchise
even after the incredible success of the
2017 film the filmmaker explained how
there was never any intention to stretch
out the story longer than necessary he
told variety how he had read about the
trilogy idea but insisted there was
never any discussion about it musetti
said I understand why they would think
that because new l originally split up
The Hobbit into three movies instead of
two but to be honest there wasn't a
conversation about that and now we are
designing the story as one single film
it's also telling that the studio
resisted the temptation to make an extra
film and squeeze more money out of the
franchise especially after the
impressive bugs office Hall of the first
movie that's a picture wrap on Bill
scars guard that's
give a return to Derry wouldn't be
complete without the return of Bill
Skarsgard as Pennywise while there was
initially some debate surrounding
whether Skarsgard would do the character
just Justice no one can dispute the
actor but his own menacing Twist on
Stephen King's Infamous demon and
despite having two it movies under his
belt it appears as if scarg guard wasn't
ready to let the Dancing Clown go yet
either after the release of it chapter 2
Skarsgard revealed to Joe Blow how he
and Andy musetti had discussed the
possibility of a third film both of them
acknowledged how it would need to be an
entirely original story since they had
mostly covered the events of the novel
Skarsgard said there are a few ideas
floating around I feel like I've done
what I can with the Incarnation of Penny
WI as we know of him so I think it would
be a cool idea to change up a few things
so without going into too much detail
there is a story that we're kind of
excited about but it's way too early to
say who knows the story of it better
than anyone else the author of the novel
of course Stephen King while a
continuation of it has never
materialized in the literary world the
writer has shown he isn't afraid of
returning to his former stomping grounds
when inspiration strikes most recently
he released Dr sleep the sequel to
1977's The Shining 36 years after the
original many fans wonder if he would
give it the same treatment especially
Tak it into account Penny wise this
plays him poop coaches Zeitgeist
appearing on Bloody Disgusting losers
Club podcast King acknowledged how
Pennywise is Clos he tied to his own
legacy as a writer even joking about how
the clown will one day Eclipse him that
being said he isn't itching to get back
into this world well I don't have a
relationship with Penny wise now because
I I have no intention of going back to
it King revealed some further context
about the upcoming welcome to Der ser
stating it will be a prequel set before
the event of the first movie and explore
the backstory of Pennywise the author
wasn't opposed to the idea either
admitting there are more than a few
intriguing storytelling possibilities to
explore in the future Gary Doberman has
built up a formidable reputation as one
of the hottest Horror filmmakers in
Hollywood he wrote all of the Annabelle
movies and even directed the third entry
in the franchise Annabelle comes home
duberman also had a hand in shaping the
direction of the it film series
co-writing the first film and taking on
the whole screenplay for chapter 2 dman
also also has his own ideas of how a
potential its chapter 3 could develop
the story further and Tackle King's Rich
law speaking to comicbookmovie.com dman
discussed how the two movies are limited
to how much mythology can be covered and
insisted there is a lot more to explore
especially in terms of the antagonist he
said there are definitely elements of
the novel you could expand on and make
its own movie it's just a question of
whether or not people want to see it but
I do think it was on this planet for a
very very very long time and that's a
lot of Bloodshed and a lot of stories to
tell and I think you could do that for
sure sure for all intents and purposes
the cosmic entity known as it is dead
after the ritual in which Penny wise had
his heart ripped out this should be a
done intested case of dingdong the clown
is gone however this is the horror genre
but death is anything but final there
are several ways of bringing back
Pennywise and it's up to the writers to
figure out how regardless of how it's
done it's important to revive the main
antagonist of the franchise whether it
comes back in the form of a clown or
something else entirely considering the
importance of 27e intervals to the story
it's chapter three should take place 27
years later and in Derry of course
nobody in the losers Club has any kids
so this could also be a chance to pass
the man to a new group of characters to
carry the story forward naturally one or
two of the original losers could return
and help out but a third installment
should offer a brand new Journey for
brand new characters not a rehash of
what came before so what would the cast
look like for a third it movie well if
Andy musetti Helms it's chapter 3 it's
obvious that there must be one name at
the top of the cast list Bill Skarsgard
taking on this version of the story
would feel strange without scar guard's
involvement even if he portrays another
incarnation of the character time to
float in addition it will be essential
to bring back at least one of the
surviving losers in terms of sheia
drawing power and star credentials that
instantly points to two actors Jessica
Chastain and James makoy considering
that Chastain's Bev married Jay ry's Ben
at the end of it chapter 2 it's also
likely that he would make an appearance
alongside her regardless of who was
chosen it would play into the movie
strengths to include at least one of the
original characters from the Beloved
group th assuming of course that any of
these actors would be willing and
available to return for chapter 3 as
with any fandom there are mixed feelings
among fans about continuing the story of
it a good portion of the audience has
read Stephen King's novel and likely
believes that the largely faithful
adaptation captures the book's tone and
message meaning there is absolutely no
need to beat this dead clown over and
over again at the same time there are
others who are curious about how the
story could continue and explore more
about Pennywise as long as it is done in
a gripping Manner and doesn't embarrass
the source material in one thread posted
on Reddit both sides of the fandom a
their opinions about whether or not the
franchise should continue one commenter
suggested that the very notion of it
chapter 3 is terrible fan service and
insisted that there is no need to
continue the story they even argued that
the third movie could turn Pennywise
into more of a caricature than a monster
another reditor said it's the losers
club that is the heart and soul of it
meaning a third movie would feel weird
without them as the main characters one
user saw both sides of the argument
writing part of me wants to see more
Pennywise but the other part remers
remers that it was the cast as a whole
that made me love chapter 1 and two plus
a little bit of mystery in the origin of
Penny wise is what makes the character
interesting it was no secret that Warner
Brothers have been eyeing a prequel for
it since the release of chapter 2
perhaps that's no surprise considering
the fans reacted so positively to the
scene in which Penny wise is shown in
his human form without any clown maker
hinting there might be more to his past
connection with the town of Derry close
your eyes be and sure enough in February
2023 it was finally confirmed that the
horror story will continue as a prequel
series for Max titled welcome to Derry
according to an article published by The
Hollywood Reporter this prequel comes
from the minds of Andy and Barbara
musetti and Jason fukes it will reveal
more of Derry and explore why the town
is so R for sinister happenings fuches
and Brad Caleb Kane are said to be co-
show Runners for the show while musetti
is scheduled to direct multiple episodes
while the news have welcomed the Der
excited those who would like to see more
of musetti's version of it some
unfortunate news arrived soon after in
an interview with Jake takes Bill
Skarsgard confirmed he had hadn't been
asked to return for the series as
Pennywise at least not at that time this
was a surprising turn of events
especially considering how pivotal scars
guard of been to the film series success
then again since it is a shape shifter
it's not outside the realm of
possibility for Penny wise to have a
different face and that's assuming scars
guard was even telling the truth taking
into account Andy musetti's involvement
in welcome to Derry is looking highly
unlikely that it chapter 3 will ever
materialize at least not as a movie that
being said musetti has admitted that he
would like to do something different
with the two it films helping to create
a super sized version of both of these
features as well as something a little
more chatting with Cinema Blend the
filmmaker explained how he wants to
include what was shot and omitted from
the theatrical Cuts while also filming
new footage he said I am thinking of a
super cut which is basically the two
movies told one after the other adding
everything that was lifted from them in
length purposes great scenes that are
more character moments or things that we
had to live for other reasons I'm also
very excited about shooting extra
material for fans this might sound like
an interesting prop position in the same
vein of The Lord of the Rings extended
editions neither Ed film was
particularly short either the first
movie clocked in at 135 minutes well the
sequel was longer at 169 minutes meaning
this super cut could become a behemoth
of a feature who knows maybe with all
the cut scenes and additional footage
this could be considered a kind of third
chapter in the it
story many count Christopher Nolan's
2006 triller The Prestige is one of his
finest films and nothing gets fans going
like a sequel so why have we never seen
the Prestige 2 let's start with the most
obvious reason why the prestige 2 hasn't
happened yet Christopher Nolan simply
hasn't expressed any intention to make a
sequel even if he wanted to it doesn't
seem like noan has the time he couldn't
release any kind of sequel right after
the release of the original because he
had his hands full with his Dark Knight
trilogy even after he finished up in
Gotham Nolan found plenty of other
projects that he presumably found more
interesting Nolan has also expressed
interest in doing a James Bond film so
he might prioritize that over a sequel
to The Prestige meanwhile some some fans
speculate that after Oppenheimer Nolan
could attempt to return to a previously
unfinished project a remake of the 1967
show The Prisoner which Nolan was
briefly attached to direct in 2009
others predict he might continue his
trend of historical films such as dun
Kirk and Oppenheimer however a sequel to
The Prestige is at least a remote
possibility that said there's still a
chance that Nolan could return to the
world of The Prestige Even after
spending more than 15 years working on
other films Nolan seems to prefer taking
a break to work on something else before
returning to direct a sequel that's what
happened with this Dark Knight trilogy
after moving away from Batman to direct
Inception Nolan came back for the Dark
Night risers later admitting to
Entertainment Weekly that the break left
him invigorated and excited to return to
Gotham City speak of the devil how this
shall appear it's worth noting that the
prestige actually originated as a small
scale project that Nolan wanted to film
in between Batman movies after releasing
Batman Begins Nolan shared that he was
open to doing a sequel but added that it
wasn't his His Highest priority in 2005
he told blackfilm well I definitely
intend to do something else first I want
to do something smaller after having
done such a big film now that Nolan has
spent over 10 years creating epic
Standalone films he might be more
willing to come back to The Prestige of
course Nolan's sentiments might also
have changed since then in a later
interview with hit Flix he said I tend
to think that if you have the chance to
do a big film you should do it while you
can I'm always worried maybe I won't be
able to do a big film again well there's
still some hope that the prestige 2
might one day come about you probably
shouldn't hold your breath judging by
how the first movie ended producing a
sequel would come with some inherent
challenges especially if it were to live
up to the original for one the absence
of few Jackman's angia would make
filming a sequel quite difficult the
Rivalry between bordon and angia sits at
the heart of the prestige yet with angia
presumed dead any sequel would be
missing that key element and while the
existence of all those clones could give
Nolan a good excuse to bring him back it
wouldn't be easy to do this without
seeming contrived Nolan could also
create a new character to to face off
against bordon but Hugh Jackman left
some pretty big shoes to fill in that
regard here has another problem we
already know exactly how angia and
bordon perform their magic tricks the
ending of The Prestige already revealed
these magicians deepest Secrets which
doesn't leave much to explore in the
sequel while it's possible that the
prestige 2 could unearth more of bord in
Secrets or introduce a new character
with their own it would be difficult to
top the reveal at the end of The
Prestige like any good magic trick a
story is less interesting to watch when
you already know how it's all pulled off
since nobody is announced a sequel to
The Prestige there's been no news from
Christian Bale on whether or not he
would return as bordon we do however
know how Bale feels about returning as
Batman which suggests how he might
respond to a potential Prestige too when
asked by comicbook.com if he would be
willing to St in a fourth Batman movie
Bale said if Christopher Nolan ever
decided to do it again and if he chose
to come my way again then yeah I would
consider it so it tracks that he would
most likely be interested in playing
Barden again so long as Nolan is
directing since Michael Kane is another
frequent Nolan collaborator it's likely
that he would be game to a priz as rool
as cutter Scarlet Johansson probably
wouldn't need much convincing to return
either she once described The Prestige
as one of the most beautiful script she
has ever read absolutely perfect and I
thought I have you know I have to do
this project I had I wanted to do it so
badly likewise Hugh Jackman loved the
prestige so much that he urged his own
production company to study Nolan's crew
as a model no doubt to be thrilled to
return as Robert angia if he were needed
When developing The Prestige Nolan
begged David Boe to accept the part of
Nicola Tesla he later told Entertainment
Weekly I told him if he didn't agree to
do the part I had no idea where I would
go from there now it's impossible to
imagine the film without Bowie and a
seel arguably wouldn't feel complete
without Tesla either alas we will not
get to see him portray Tesla again since
Bowie died in 2016 still noan might
figure out a way to create a sequel even
without Bowie's presence after all Nolan
managed to write a fitting conclusion to
Batman's story without the Joker and
without making his absence obvious
speaking about the fact that the Joker
is barely mentioned in the Dark Knight
RIS say no than told Empire that is
something I felt very strongly about in
terms of my relationship with Heath and
the experience I went through with him
on the Dark Knight I didn't want to do
in any way try and account for a real
life tragedy that seemed inappropriate
to me so if noan does ever decide to
make the prestige 2 it seems unlikely
that Tesla will have any part to play
even off screen if the prestige 2 ever
comes to fruition there are countless
possible story lines it could explore at
the end of The Prestige we saw Alfred
bordon reuniting with his daughter and
presumably retiring from the stage but
the sequel could well follow bordon as
he returns to the magician's lifestyle
once more if angia isn't coming back at
all another character from the first
movie could easily step up to play an
antagonistic role who better to cross
swords with bordon than his former
assistant Olivia she knows most of his
tricks after all meanwhile Borden's
Obsession might lead him to all but
abandon his daughter Jess who would now
be a teenager or maybe the hopes to
train her as his assistant and eventual
successor there are so many paths that
Prestige sequel could tread basically
anything Could
Happen John C Riley once said that he
can't leave his house without being
asked about a Step Brother sequel but
fans expecting more silly Shenanigans
from Brennan and Dale are going to be
disappointed here's why ever since
Brennan huff and Dale Doak resolved
their differences fans of Step Brothers
have wanted to see more did we just
become best friends yep the 2008 box
office hit ret team Talladega night
Stars will farell and John C Riley as
immature grown men who still mooch off
their parents and nearly destroy
everyone's lives in the process while
everything ended happily Step Brothers
generated so many ridiculous scenes and
memorable lines that it's almost
inconceivable that a sequel never enter
production and you're not going to not
get Randy Jack's autograph right I would
have done the exact same thing so why
didn't Ferell Riley and director Adam
McKay ever revisit Brennan Dale and
their messy family Dynamic over the last
decade and a half well after the success
of Step Brothers a the follow-up film
was actually in the works but as McKay
told collider Paramount Pictures asked
him and frell to make a different sequel
Anchor Man 2 after filming that 2013
sequel McKay and frell decided they
didn't want to do another Step Brothers
anymore McKay explained to the outlet I
don't want to get into the sequel
business too much McKay wanted to try
new things and subsequently he built a
lane for himself as a filmmaker of
satirical comedies like Vice and don't
look up but Step Brothers 2 is even less
likely to happen now following a
professional and personal falling out
between McKay and Ferell that revolved
around their step brother's collaborator
John C Riley in 2019 McKay and frell
announced that they had ended their
creative partnership and closed their
company Gary Sanchez Productions years
later the reasons behind the split
emerged as an executive producer McKay
helped bring winning time the rise of
the Lakers Dynasty the HBO in 2022
winning time Stars Riley as team owner
Jerry bus although Ferell lobbied hard
for that role McKay gave it to Riley
without letting frell know McKay told
Vanity Fair I should have called him and
I didn't the director also went on to
say that he and frell no longer speak to
each other additionally both Riley and
frell have told reporters that a sequel
to Step Brothers is a highly unlikely
proposition in a 2018 interview with
screen Crush Riley explained that he and
Ferell as well as Adam McKay would
rather pursue new projects instead of
making a stepbrother sequel unless we
really sure that we could do a better
version or improve on what it is let's
leave it alone as for frell he admits
he's thought about a sequel but
ultimately decided against it the actor
told Rolling Stone in 2017 you have to
resist the temptation It's just tough
because the things everyone wants you to
do sequels of are special because
there's not a sequel of it but even
though A Step Brothers 2 will probably
never get made Adam McKay said that he
and his collaborators have already
worked out a plot for a potential sequel
McKay told collider we have a whole
story and outline that we're happy with
although McKay didn't reveal any more
information about the plot will frell
shared the fleshed out premise for Step
Brothers 2 with the New York daily news
in 2017 As frell Told the outlet the
sequel would have centered around
Brennan and Dale moving into a
retirement community with their aging
parents played by Richard Jenkins and
Mary Steen bin so if a Step Brothers 2
was to ever happen would the entire cast
return well seeing the original film is
a buddy comedy it would be Unthinkable
to make a sequel without either frell or
Riley reprising their roles furthermore
while discussing possible plot lines for
a sequel both frell and McKay mentioned
significant roles for Brennan and Dale's
parents so this means Mary Steamin and
Richard Jenkins would need to return as
Nancy huff and Robert doc fortunately
Steamin told screen Crush that she'd be
happy to appear in a sequel the Oscar
winner told the outlet I would be there
day one with the biggest smile in my
face I love those guys and the joy of
working with them Step Brothers also
featured Adam Scott and Katherine Han in
supporting roles both actors would go on
to find greater levels of Fame on shows
like Parks and Recreation and W division
filmmakers would certainly want their
star power in Step Brothers too so it's
a good thing that Han is definitely on
board